there's such a wide variety of what
being gay can mean so like up in the
locker room when you tap your buddy's
ass like this was a tough one because
like I have I definitely have like
straight friends who wouldn't do
anything with me even though I find them
very attractive and I joke I joke around
with them like dude I'd hit I know they
wouldn't do anything I think a lot I
think a lot of straight guys don't do it
because it's like oh no homo bro no homo
thing is like so social if you guys like
actually stood away from that and like
experimented and try it out for
yourselves you might actually find out
that you like some certain things
I mean well sexuality is definitely a
spectrum and I think there's so many
things between the spectrum but there
also are those two polar opposites ends
of the spectrum so I think people
definitely do identify as very very
straight and very very gay and the only
reason I'm on this line is because of
what you said like there's a spectrum
right so there's such a wide variety of
what being gay can mean so like up in
the locker room and you tap your buddy's
ass like nestled well gay you know
hi guys so I think this is more of a
multi-faceted question because I
consider gay as not just who you're
sexually attracted to it's part of an
entire experience so if they discover
themselves and they realize hey maybe I
could have a relationship with someone
of the same sex does that mean they
magically became bi at that point where
they born that way definitely I agree I
don't think that people are born gay
however I do I do think people are born
with like certain tendencies that can
line up with being gay if that makes
sense so like being a little more
sensitive or being like not having an
interest in sports but having more
interest in art it's kind of like like a
bucket and you just happen to have all
these little tiny things in your bucket
when you're born but that doesn't make
you gay kind of thing so then in that
regard then would you say that being gay
is a choice because that's absolutely
not a choice because you can ask any
straight person be gay for a day it's
not a choice
and I think you guys were kind of
touching upon more than just a sexuality
aspect some of the cultural aspects the
mannerisms being gay I think those are
culturally learned things and also
things that you're comfortable with and
how you express yourself but I think
from like a sexuality standpoint you
mean sexuality develops as you're going
through puberty and like you're not like
you know coming out of the womb like hey
let's like have sex you know like you're
a child you're developing it and it's
kind of growing as you grow and so you
know you don't choose you you just have
to you know
[Music]
personally I'm a really feminine fun
buoyant person so just having that same
energy with another person just doesn't
seem really attractive to me I wants to
find someone who's like different unique
and someone I can learn from so just
like having someone who's almost
identical or similar to me I feel like I
wouldn't grow enough I'm on this line
because I want someone who is my equal
like I identify as a masculine man
therefore I think the reason I strongly
agree is just because I want that
equality in my relationship as a
masculine man I think yes there's a lot
of innate attraction of what what you
like what you're born with but like also
there's so much I think there's a lot of
social pressure that you don't even
realize it's happening so I'm
consciously of what like you're trained
to like because I do like masculine men
as well and then I was like kind of
taking a step back like wait why is that
why do I like that like I'm a being that
kind of force-fed that when I was
growing up you know gay men were defined
as feminine and I was feminists had a
lot of feminine characteristics as a
young boy and not you know and I I was
singled out because of that and bullied
some because of that but I was sort of
was always drawn to people who were
masculine and I don't know if it's
because if there were people who were
feminine that reminded me of parts of
myself I didn't like I think there's
probably an aspect of that but you're
sort of you're sort of attracted to what
you're attracted to I think there's not
a lot of logic
three two
I think Gras grinder and like dating
apps are a really complex topic I think
I think there's a lot of good and a lot
of bad for me personally I think the bad
outweighs the good specifically grinder
the way it's set up it's a very hookup
based app and so like it really taught
me to like see other gay men is like
more objects and more of like pieces of
beat kind of thing than actual people
well me personally I'm more like a like
a romantic guy like I'm in I'm in it for
like the long run with someone kind of
so the fact that a lot of the guys that
I have went out with only wanted sex I
think has a lot to do I think has a lot
to do with like dating apps like Grindr
where it's just like sex base I think it
fuels that like sex fire that a lot of
gay men seem to have I think there need
to be more arenas in which gay men can
meet each other I'm a gay father I have
a daughter he's 18 a son he's 13
when I was growing up the idea of gay
men growing up and getting married and
being monogamous and being happy and
having children was from Mars and when I
my husband and I were starting to have
our kids we went with a group of people
called the potluck club and it was gay
men who wanted to become fathers and it
wasn't until that time that I finally
found my tribe I get it was like oh my
god these are people like me but they
weren't any sort of gay stereotype they
just wanted to have families and that's
what you don't see on Grindr or anywhere
else like that
I am on somewhat disagree because I
believe Pride Month was necessary
because we were in a time where gays
weren't allowed to be who they are and
and basically everything we are now and
that's great I just think like the Pride
Month was good when we needed it and
it's good to keep up with traditions but
I think it just goes a little too far
sometimes for me personally coming out
to I think for everybody it's it's a
process from the time you begin to
realize you're gay until you hopefully
can fully accept it one day there were
years where it was like I would never go
near that price I would like go six
blocks out of the way not to be
associated with it because it was so
scary to me and it was a gradual process
and the first time I did do it it was
the most empowering moment just to be
part of that same feeling - yeah I think
I think pride is so important I think
pride is so so important and like
because I mean we have a lot more rights
than we did 50 60 years ago but like
we're still not equal citizens in a lot
of places and we're still not equal in a
lot of people's eyes and like why does
every goddamn day just like being
yourself authentically without any
questions and just like fighting for
what you believe in it's still so
important though everyday just to really
be proud of who you are and really
express that and try and you know change
the world with what you can do
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys my name is Michael I mean thank
you so much for watching this episode of
spectrum it's so amazing to see where
people will stand in the line in the
process of making spectrum as a series
what do you think there's something
you've learned Oh every time I do this
series my mind opens to like I don't
know a different galaxy but the biggest
thing I learned is like no everyone
doesn't think the same which is pretty
obvious but well it's not obvious
sometimes right exactly that's good too
good pictures Elia thank you for
watching you guys follow us on instagram
at jubilee media we post a lot of
different kind of stuff for you guys and
we also love just interacting with you
and yeah follow us on everywhere
everyone we'll see you around